I don't think there is a well maybe that could be true.
Maybe we should record the whole thing again.
Hello everyone and welcome to the very one hundred and sixty-sixth
Episode of Octothorpe, a podcast for science fiction and science fiction fandom, which is befriending a murderous clown.
On the 13th of August 2026, I'm John Coxon.
I'm Alison Scott.
And I'm Liz Batty.
And we have some letters of comment.
We heard from Simon Bubb and he wrote us a detailed email about 18xx games.
um which is um very interesting.
Thank you very much to Simon.
He recommends as a beginner or introductory one, eighteen forty six, eighteen thirty, eighteen eighty-nine
Shikoko and 18 Chesapeake.
But I found out at the weekend when Rosanna and Ed were visiting that there is a game called 21 Moon
where you uh go on the moon and you make the moon trains.
And and it's an 18xx called 21 Moon.
Yes.
Excellent.
One of the things I think is the very lazy about the 18XX community is that sometimes they don't bother actually coming up with a year.
They just do 18 and then the location.
Yeah, Francis Tresham will be rolling in his grave.
And this is 21 the location, because this isn't the 1800s, this is the 2100s.
It says on the cover, the race to exploit space.
And Simon also refers to Cube Rails games.
um which are kind of a shorter related family uh they're kind of a related family of games which are
tend to be shorter play times.
And I believe I've played a cube rail game, uh but I can't remember what it was called.
I think it might just have been called Trains
Yeah, that's a bad name for your board game.
Yeah, yeah, so I'm I'm just searching BoardGameGeek for the word trains.
That's gonna go well.
Well yeah, no, I mean this is the thing, right?
I did.
It was called trains.
It is the top
result on BoardGameGeek for the word trains and it is hexagons and cubes in a very part of the problem is that the train lines aren't train lines, they're little cubes.
And it's like, well a tra cube isn't a train line.
Make it look like a train line.
Yeah, should clearly be uh stick.
This is why we like Railway Rivals and other games where you get to draw your train lines.
Um I recommended Rollway Station, which is a very short 18XX roll and write.
It's not really an 18XX because it does have tiles.
It has draw it has things that you draw on a map because it's a roll of writer to John.
Um that's the shortest 18XX type game I've played.
Yes, thank you very much for writing in Simon.
And I have threatened Liz with the prospect of playing the Tynan Tees map for Railway Rivals and uh Liz reacted with the
indicating no person emoji.
Um so I don't think Liz wants to.
Look, if if I just have to make the sacrifice of never ever visiting John again, I will.
Y you you realise I'm completely up for playing the Tyrone T's version of Railway Rivals, John.
I don't know when we're likely to see you, but you know, one day.
Yeah, yeah.
No, that's fair.
Um I'll put a link in the show notes, listeners.
Perry Ann Lurie wrote to remind us
um that the Worcester Study rules apply only to Wisforce activities and not to the running of a Worldcon, which I think we've said before on the POP, but I think we should make it clear.
WOSFAS has almost no control over how the Worldcon is run and that's by design.
You know, there's it's got like things like service box.
And I think we'll be coming back to this a little bit later.
Maybe.
That's it.
And yes, D D C changed dates because of COVID, but also because their convention hotel shut down permanently.
I think we we said that last time though.
Well I think I think the point Le Perrian is making is that they the hotel released Discon from the contract.
Yeah, well th they were bust, which is a f fairly drastic way of of releasing somebody from a contract.
And um that says that the Worldcon
Runners Guide Editorial Committee used to be a standing committee of Whisfus, um but hasn't reported in many years.
It could be reconstituted with a chairperson who will do the work.
But I think we know from other attempts to do this that actually codifying
things about how to run conventions is quite hard.
Partly hard because it's hard and partly hard because it's difficult to persuade people to do the work when they've just run a Worldcon.
Cause I think the reason we have bad documentation is largely because you need to be writing things down as you're going, when you're busy, uh or after you stop, when you'd like a rest.
But
Props to Fiona Anderson who created another fine Nessie from all of the area heads and division heads in nineteen ninety-five, I think, which is a very long time ago.
But that exists.
So it is possible to do it, but you you probably need somebody who takes it very seriously and is um
It's brutal enough to extract documents from people after the convention.
Yeah.
I mean and and these things do go out of date, right?
Like I read bits of Another Fine Nessie and it's about that's a problem.
You put a lot of effort in, but I mean
How how long do the messages actually remain useful for?
Like I think a lot of another fine Nessie, there's some large bits about like how you communicate.
Right, and whether you should use email and things like that.
Yeah.
So so I mean it's it's interesting primarily as a historical artifact.
But I mean there are plenty of lessons that are still perfectly relevant today.
But that's also true when you read um
you know, writings of Greeks and Romans, which is why people do it.
So uh but the stuff that is is dated has dated.
I mean one of the things
I hope we're doing on Octhorpe is codifying like some of what we think about how conventions should be run.
And obviously that's just three people, but hopefully that is contributing to this conversation in small some small way
and trying to take some of the load off the people actually doing the work and moving it on to people who are doing less work but commentating on the work.
Hopefully that's one of the things we can bring to the table.
Three very opinionated people, John.
Yes, and also in uh I mean it's not inaccessible, but I think podcasts there's transcripts and everything, but I'm not sure we are the most accessible media for take home lessons.
This is more the discussion bit that would lead to something more concrete?
No, I think you're right.
I mean one of the things I like about doing a podcast is that it's slightly harder to listen to than it is to like read something.
So I think it means we get less, um Angry letters?
Well yeah, the people who listen to us know what we're like, and there are relatively few people who encounter the things we say without knowing what we're like.
And that's nice.
Yeah, we know what you're like, John.
Yeah.
Thank you very much for writing in Perri Ann.
Doug Thornt wrote in he was in London, so he went to Nando's and he wants to know what our favourite Nando's is
And I get the double chicken breast wrap with added halloomy, Doug.
And I don't get to Dando's very often because I think the thing that is best about Nando's is his exciting periperi sauce and I have to not have it but have the
mild sauce for wassues instead, which is fine.
I tend to like boneless chicken in general.
But actually I'd rather go to Popeye's than Nando's.
Oh, that is that is a that is a statement.
I know that's a take.
We had we went to Popeye's the other night.
Pretty good.
I mean I also don't go to Nando's very much.
I would probably get the butterfly chicken with some creamy mash and corn on the cob.
Nice.
It's almost exactly what I had when we went out with Scott in fact.
Aww.
We we we've got a Dave's hot chicken in Newcastle now.
I've not visited yet.
The typography in the uh in the in the sign annoys me.
It's not a smart quote and it's very sad.
I thought it wasn't a quote at all.
Yeah, well that's the other thing.
So in Birmingham there's no quote and in Newcastle there is a quote but it's straight and I'm like sort it out.
Oh yeah
There were straight quotes in the subtitles.
We went to a subtitle version of the Odyssey and there were straight quotes in it.
I was very annoyed.
To be fair, they didn't invoke curly quotes until after Greek times, so that's just realistic.
Also not English, also not subtitles, also not movies.
I mean these are minor points.
We heard from new Mark Protection Committee member Andrew January.
Congratulations Andrew.
Woo woo!
Who, as we said, did the F.
9 change
to the Whispers Business Meeting, which was to fitch an ex case in the QGOs.
Um and we passed that.
So well done Andrew.
He did say he did start modelling the history of constitution as a Git repo
but actually it's quite tedious and the formatting changes a lot at the start and so if he were to attempt it again he would probably work backwards.
And now maybe he's gonna do that and I feel slightly guilty
Sorry, Andrew.
Yes.
We previously put a link to Andrew's um excellent constitutional amendment visualization tool.
in the show notes listeners, so go back and look for that if you'd like to visit it.
Dave Langford wrote to us and said he can't manage the audio but often looks through the transcripts and in the traditional fan phrase which I'd never heard of, am fantisted by the scoop and power of the message.
Um he says there is some mystery about where wounded wombats come from and I think they come from the sake story Reginald's Rabayat.
which we can link to in the show notes, where one of his bright young men is proud of Have you heard the groan of a gravelled grouse, or the snarl of a snuffled snail, husband or mother like me or spouse
Have you lay a creep in the darkened house where the wounded wombats wail?
Hoping you are the same.
All o all of Sucky's out of copyright and if you've not read anything by Sucky, it is all absolutely hilarious.
It has it is obviously of of its tie, but it's very, very funny.
And it's part of a
It it it's part of a series of Reginald.
So I will link on Wikisource, which appears to be the Wikipedia
Site for out of copyright text.
Thank you very much for bringing in, Dave.
We heard from Zara Baxter.
Hello Zara.
I hope you're well.
Who says
They have finally joined the Octothorpe Resolu Revolution.
Um, it's good to have you.
They mention having to really go back and dig through all the details of Chengdu.
Ooh.
Oh, oh, oh, don't do that.
Sorry Zara and um Zara is living in Adelaide, which is in Australia.
So I assume you're looking forward to Brisbane, Zara.
But yes, hello!
I haven't seen Zara in ages.
She says our summer theme music reminds her of the Great Pottery Throwdown.
I haven't seen the Great Pottery Throwdown, but I'm told it's good.
We also heard from Christopher J.
Garcia, who titles his letter Lock on the Episode where Liz said I should say which episode?
Thanks very much, Chris.
I mean yep, I think that's fair.
And emotionally discusses the business meeting, which will segue us nicely into
business meeting, maybe final section on the business meeting, who knows?
Um Q, I need a sound effect which is the cheers of our listeners.
And me.
And he says, I was glad to see the confusing voting protocol proposal sent committee with a short time frame to return.
Yes, so this was my confusing voting proposal.
Which was F named F point eight and we said last time you might know by this episode if we'd passed it.
And what we actually did is it was a bit confusing and the wording needed fixing, so we sent it to committee, we had some discussions
over the week and then we brought it back again and passed it.
Which is nice.
Chris says Do voters really need to understand how things work or just accept there's a complicated engine under the hood?
Which is a I think a tricky
A tricky discussion because it was clear that a lot of people do not understand how the proposed voting system uh we suggested works
And then you are left with, well, do I sit down and try and figure it out or do I take it for granted that the word of the people who say this is better and it will work are correct?
And I think that is a genuinely tricky question.
So I think there might be some work over the next year to maybe explain it in multiple
different ways so that we find one that means people can understand it.
I mean I think this is the same for the Hugos.
I think as we've discovered a lot of people do not actually fully understand EPH.
But I've kind of accepted that it seems to work okay.
And this is very similar.
But it would be nice.
I don't want to deliberately I'm not deliberately trying to make things super confusing, nor do I want people to be actually confused about how voting works for the NPC.
But I do want it to be a bit more proportional.
So I'll think about that.
Yeah, I thought it was interesting.
There was some interesting discussion, a lot of which I missed due to being asleep at during the Bids the Business meeting that we're actually discussing my proposal.
But there you go.
I was not as sure it was as confusing as some other people thought it was.
But um it was probably better to make sure it was as unconfusing as it could have been.
Yeah.
And the thing is it's certainly possible that there are ways to write it that are less confusing to some people, but possibly more confusing to other people.
And we
Did some minor tweaks in committee, but we didn't try and tweak the whole thing because then you really want to make sure you haven't introduced any accidental loopholes.
Yes.
Because then Andrew January would have to find out where they were and propose an amendment to fix 'em.
Yes, that is true.
Oh, and Chris also says it's pronounced esphus.
There you go.
Good.
Yes.
Thank you very much for bringing in, Chris
The second and third main business meetings happened since the last episode, and the
Um second one was held in unexecutive session, and then the other one was held in executive session, which basically means uh you can't discuss it unless you're a member of the society.
Yeah.
The second
That business meeting went at a fiery pace and finished early, having finished all its business.
Has never happened before, I think.
We will link in the show notes, um, but effectively
The stuff we liked passed, the stuff we didn't like didn't pass, and there was one controversial one, which was de
End the false binary one.
I would argue that um the actual thing that we passed is not the controversial bit.
It makes the language clearer
As to what it actually does, and I think what actually does might be the controversial bit, but basically this is to do with uh the pro and fan artist categories, listeners
Yeah, I I I said something in this meeting and then all my friends rounded on me and was like, Well your problem with is with the definition of the Hugos, not this not this um description of them and I'm like
Yeah, no, that's probably right.
Um, and then since then everyone's been saying, So what do you want?
And I'm like, I don't know.
I want clever people to work out what I want.
I think it's tricky, right?
It is tricky.
Somebody who hasn't who didn't tell me whether this was D and Q or not, so I'm not gonna out them said
I think everyone really wants something that'll let fan artist award Hugos to their friends but not to people they don't know.
And I thought that was very mean.
but possibly accurate.
I think there is a y the y yes, I think there might be a little bit of that, maybe.
Basically for those who don't know, the pro artist
Hugo is explicitly for artists who are paid to do illustrations and this has the advantage that historically this had the advantage that most of what we considered pro art in our field and most of what actually gets nominated is
b people who do book covers and that is defined that comes under that umbrella.
But it does have the side effect that literally all other art is technically fan art and that may be a bad thing.
It's widely considered to be a bad thing, I think.
But then w yes.
But then we get into the the thorny thing of, well how do we make it so that fan art isn't literally all art?
without accidentally cutting out some art we'd quite like to keep in fan art.
And therein, listeners, lies the very difficult bit.
I think it I think that is a fair characterization.
I think it would require careful thought.
And and so some people have promised to do some careful thought.
Including me.
And then there's also the other thing that happened in that which was
a responsive late business, the proposal that suggested that you need to do something if committees didn't respond and I went, Oh hang on, well we could just make committees respond earlier has been remitted to a committee which will respond early, probably.
Um I've said I'm happy to serve on that committee but not to chair it.
So hopefully someone will be happy to chair it.
If that committee reports late that would be pretty funny though.
Very
It it would it would be very funny.
One of the things I'll say when it gets going is I really think we should report at least two months before the
Well gone.
At least a m a good month before the business deadline.
It was generally it was generally all quite sensible.
There's not much drama.
You know, apart from apart from um Liz, nobody's tired or terribly fractious.
Yeah.
Congratulations also.
I I believe, I don't know whether Warren Buff
listens, but I believe Alana Vincent does listen, so congratulate or congratulations also to Alana for being elected to the MPC.
Alana did sterling work on the Ethics Committee.
Which we passed the recommendations of.
Largely there were minor changes.
Anything else on that?
I think my only comment would be that it is the business meeting seems to be quite in tune with how
w our our opinions, which is interesting.
We're just very influential.
I don't think we are.
I think we are kind of
tied into what I think of as the primary business meeting faction at the moment.
I think in general, and perhaps I am wrong
But in general, I don't think any of the three of us are a s sort of significant distance away from what most people reckon on most issues.
At the moment.
As we age, listeners, obviously this will get worse.
Okay, speak for yourself.
Ha ha ha
I think I'm doing a great job of keeping in tune with the zeitgeist.
Yeah, but when you're 90 Allison, I reckon you're gonna be uh demanding that the UK be that there be a fence around the UK separating us from Europe.
and demanding that we attack the moon people.
So so that's not how it works, but yeah probably.
And also, will we still be doing Octothorpe?
I'll be like, Oh, I'm not sure how this switch works.
Oh god, every t we've got a hard car and I think I I'm perfectly happy to put this on a
the podcast.
Every single time we leave the higher car, Stephen has to walk a certain distance away from the car, hand the keys to somebody.
Go back and check that the car is not now opening and then come back and then we go on our way.
That's fair.
That is fair.
I'm with Stephen on that one.
So we believe we are allowed to tell you what the resolutions were that were passed by the third Bain business meeting.
Because although the
Substantive discussion is limited.
The resolutions that were passed will be added in some form to the public-facing Wusfus documentation.
And if we can't, the next session of this podcast will be repl replaced by some incidental music by John.
Okay, so I could not attend this meeting because of, you know, tapas and beer in intervening, but I
I kind of watched some of the discussions going on.
I want to thank the trial committee for doing all their huge amount of work in advance and making all this happen and also to the Wisp's business meeting staff.
for keeping what quite a complicated discussion on track and focused and making and getting to the end of it.
I thought that was all very good.
I think none of that is controversial to say under any circumstances.
Yeah, I I think you could even generalize.
I think it's not just from the virtual business meetings, but over the past, I don't know, N years that I've been going to business meetings, I think we have been doing
better and better jobs of explaining what is going on, trying to keep things clear even in the face of sometimes complicated rules of order and the current business meeting staff are really good at it.
Yeah.
And I would include Zazar in that
Zaza is the dog?
Yes.
Zaza is Jesse's dog.
And um Jesse wrote in to say that unfortunately they had to turn the noise suppression back on on their Zoom and so we could not hear
little doggy snores in the later meetings.
And I think there probably be there may be a general feeling that we would like more doggy snores, but we can't get them on demand.
That doggy snores would improve the meeting generally.
Yes.
That is the business meeting
Until site selection, that is all of the business meeting, and site selection will just be telling you that Brisbane won, unless something very strange happens.
So that is probably it for the year.
Everyone, everyone, you can come back.
You can c you can come back.
We've stopped.
It's safe now.
D do we have anything else to talk about though?
Um swim headphones
Yep.
Last night while we were sitting around uh eating lovely tapas and drinking beer, um a representative sample of our listeners, which is to say Lillian and Christina
said how much they had enjoyed all of the swim headphone content.
I can we do a lot more of that and a lot less of things like whispers that were boring.
That's a a representative fac faction of our listeners.
So I think we're done with swim he swim headphones.
Get the shocks
We will but we'll find other things to go off and digress about in the future, I promise.
Yeah, I mean I'm I'm tempted to do more more swim headphone chat until people realise it's just gonna be us saying, Yeah, we all have the same swim headphones, guys.
And this is not an accident.
I think it is an accident, isn't it?
Anyway, no swim headphone chat.
Onwards.
We have exciting news, listeners.
We have been invited to be guests
For OctoCon 2026, we will be online guests.
And this is a very great honor
Thank you very much to OctoCon.
I've never been invited to be a guest before.
No, me neither.
So Octo
OctoCon 2026 is both online and in person and it is at the following dates which I wish I knew because it would be good to know them before I started this sentence.
3rd and 4th of October, 2026.
Our vague plan is that we will do Octhorpe Live at ten o'clock in the morning.
on the fourth of October, which will just be what we normally do, except with you guys on Zoo as well.
We've done that before.
Um but we'll work out with
We'll work out with OctoCon how they want to do that and we'll probably be elsewhere on the programme as well.
But I don't I I I d I haven't filled in the form yet due to being on holiday.
There must be a form, right?
There is, yes.
Yes, you've both got actions.
I've done my actions.
Well done.
So we're very pleased, thank you.
Um very look looking forward to it.
It's very exciting.
If you do go to OctoCon in person, they have two great guests of honour, Adrian Trikowski and Katie Murphy.
They also have Premier Mohammed as an online guest of honour and other uh in-person guests for certain days and more online guests and it all looks very exciting.
Yes.
And I
I have been a guest twice before at online things.
Um I was um a guest at the kind of BSFA foundation AGM in I think twenty twenty one, but it might have been twenty twenty.
Um and I was a guest at
one of the New Zealand national cons online.
Um if anyone would like to fly me to New New New Zealand to be a guest of honour, I would love that too.
Let me know
Indeed.
Or indeed anywhere, you know.
I think we have not done an online
recording with guests since punctuation two.
Is that right?
Yeah, that was quite a while ago.
Yeah, no, it's not something we very normally do.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah.
Though I was online at was it Reclamation where I caught COVID during the con and then we recorded with me from my sickbed.
Or was that conversation?
It must have been conversation.
I can't remember.
Conversation, it was conversation, yeah.
Yeah, so that so the last time we did this would have been the twentieth of June 2021, I think.
Oh really?
Ah, it's it's been a while.
Yeah, five years.
That's weird.
That's a weird fact.
That's exciting.
Yeah, no
It's a weird feeling.
So I assume this is going to be on the program and OctoCon members and then we'll need to get the but we'll we'll work it out.
Yes, I imagine if you want to come, you're going to have to join OctoCon listeners.
Uh we'll put a link to Octocon in the show notes.
Which you should do anyway.
I mean I went during the pandemic when they were online a bit and it was good fun.
And now and now they are
In person and online so you can all go.
Yes.
Alright, thank you very much to OctoCon.
Oh and we should say out loud
For those who don't know, Ogon is the National Irish Science Fiction Convention.
And the only one I've been to in person, I've been to a couple of the online ones, but the only one I've been to in person was the very first one a very, very long time ago
For all of you out there, online membership to OctoCon is 20 euros or 10 euros for concessions.
Um so it's not if you want to hear a sort of the first
Octothorpe live zoom in in five years.
This is this is not a huge amount to ask, I think.
So please all join.
It'd be good.
Be good fun.
I mean, y you'll be able to get the podcast afterwards in the normal way.
We'll we'll r we'll um we'll put it out like we normally do.
But maybe we'll maybe we should do some exclusive bits for the OctoCon membership.
But we always do anyway, don't we, whenever we record something live.
That is one of the benefits of seeing things live, yeah.
Some deliberate exclusive bits.
Not the fuck ups.
Well we'll be on program and stuff.
I think.
Yeah, we we could be on the programme elsewhere as well.
I don't know what they'll how they're gonna use us.
And shall we talk about LA Con five?
Membership still available, listeners, so um, you know, go get your membership.
It's the 27th of August to the 31st, um, with various guests of honour and special guests.
What are you guys doing at LACOM 5?
I am going to be in a field.
So I
I ha I am a attending member and partly because I wanted to go to the business meeting, but also partly because I tend to see some of the convention on catch up.
But I'm not actually doing anything over the weekend of A Lacon because I am going to a folk festival that weekend
Instead.
Because I haven't had enough sunshine yet this summer.
And I will be partly on a plane, partly in my house, partly in the office during um Wolcon.
The timing was just
Not very good for me and also the time zone is not very good for me.
So I will be dropping in and out of things online and watching catch up and I do have a virtual membership but I am also not doing anything
Which is by choice.
They were very n the the LA Con team have been very nice and have sent multiple reminders to say if you would like to do something on programme, please do fill out this form.
Please do fill out this form.
Please do like, let us know.
And I have chosen to uh not do anything.
And so we're leaving all the Oxthorp representation to John.
John, can you handle it?
I am ready.
What are you doing, John?
I'm on program, Liz.
So the guide is on the internet.
You can view my program and I am on a couple of items on most days, except for the Monday.
I don't know how I've escaped the Monday.
But um but I have.
So I'm on a couple of things about science on the Thursday, and I'm on a fancasty one and a sciencey one on the Friday.
And on the Saturday, I'm on a Fancasty one and a gaming E1 and a game show.
And then on the Sunday, I'm on
Uh some sciencey ones and some gamey ones.
That's basically Fancast Science and Games.
So the one I'm most excited about or well, I'm excited about all of them.
But I will be um moderating a panel with uh Greg Kasavin and Jennifer Svedberg-Yen, um who wrote Hades 2 and Claire Obscure Expedition 33, respectively, on the Sunday.
Oh God, oh my god.
Yeah, that's the one I am most annoyed about not being at.
And it's not streamed.
God damn it.
Oh no!
Oh and it's not being streamed!
Oh my god, can you just kind of record it on your phone or something?
Oh, oh Jesus
It might be a code of conduct violation.
But no, I think that one might be good.
When people look at this, um Taskmaster is currently still on the programme, but that has been removed, so I'm not gonna be Taskmastering
Which is a bit of a shame, but there we are.
Um but I am excited, I'm gonna be on Inconceivable, the game show of Nerdery and Nonsense, which I am ex very excited about that.
Alison is still mad because she can't see the Hades II Clubscure panel.
Sorry.
I am not full of I am I am I am that's always well it's not it's just it's Hades II and Clubscure Expedition thirty three, which I think are
are both very interesting games in terms of storytelling design.
Yes.
I'm sure that's what they will talk about.
Maybe John will give us some highlights later.
And John's moderating it, so I mean I don't know how I'd I I I would be all oh squee, squee, squee I would be too fan girly to moderate that panel, I think
Yeah, I genuinely cannot predict a winner in that category.
I mean it could be blueprints.
I think a lot of people like blueprints, but people really also really like Hades.
People like Claire Obscure as well, and I don't know the I think p people there are proponents for all of these games.
This is a great category.
Yeah
No, I mean the game category is, I think, a very strong category and has been showcasing good games.
What do you guys
What are you blah, is there anything you're looking forward to on catch-up or streaming that y has caught your eye?
I haven't looked at the program yet.
That was the first thing if it if everything on the program is as exciting as that panel, I I'm
Going to be very sad I didn't get on a plane and go to LA.
I had look, there is a lot of stuff.
I think there's a lot of nice panels that they've kind of designed around the QGO finalists
Which is uh a quite a nice way of honouring them.
I think there's quite a strong set of interesting looking panels on romanticy and uh supernatural romance, which is quite nice 'cause maybe we don't always cover that in much depth, but if you've got the people to do it then it's a good
Uh a good thing to cover.
Some of the science panels look pretty solid.
Honestly I haven't looked at it and I'm not gonna look at it till I'm in the right time zone because otherwise I'll just be sad about the things that I can't watch live.
I'll probably um
One of the things I'll be doing is once the Discord opens, because I do like Worldcon Discords, I will start hanging out on the Discord a bit, which is something I probably will even do from a field.
And then you can get a you get a sense of what things everyone else is looking forward to and what things are getting buzzed on the on the Discord.
And I this is one of the things I really, really like about conventional discords
But yeah, by the time we're doing a proper octethorpe again, um the convention will be over, I think, because I think the next one is a filler.
So Yes, next time we're dropping a episode that we've recorded out of time
And then the uh one after that will be the post LA conalysis.
Yeah, so I will try to watch some things on catcher before that.
Yeah, don't don't call it a filler episode, Alison.
Call it, you know, finely curated entertainment we we made earlier.
A blue pizza episode.
Yeah no I I get our our audience is gonna understand that aren't they?
I mean some of them.
Quite a lot of them.
I mean I think
But most people will understand filler episode.
Bottle episode.
There are bottle episodes.
A flexible episode.
No, now we're just getting to silly.
Flexibode
I I noticed now, having looked at your um Alecon things in slightly more detail, that all of the fancasters are doing a live show together
Yes!
And that's gonna be a laugh, guys.
I think that'll be very good.
Yes, so there's there's one which is um
So I'm on a panel with Amy Zally of Hugo Girl, Gary Kaywolf of Cood Street, Natania Barron of World Building for Masochists.
Tss.
Uh and Scott Edelman, who as we know, does Eating the Fantastic, is moderating, and we will be talking about
running a fan cast and so that should be interesting.
But then we're doing a It's the second one that's excited me, I have to say.
Yeah, and then we're doing one called Many Mics One Stage, which is
Me, Kevin and Laurie Anderson from Hugo Girl, Marshall Ryan Moreska and Cass Morris from World Building for Masochists, and Cassella from Hill of Fawns, we're gonna do a podcast.
Yeah, and and there's no moderator for that one, you're just gonna get on and do it, it's gonna be good.
Yup.
And then I guess
I guess it'll be recorded and it will come out somewhere as a podcast.
Expect lively exchanges, unexpected connections, and a celebration of fanish audio creativity.
I think I'm expecting nonsense.
I think there's gonna be nonsense.
I'm looking forward to doing boob talk with Laurie and Kevin before diving into a deep analysis of something with Casella.
And uh you know, it's gonna be interesting.
I don't know, I assume we're all gonna do picks.
I don't know which parts of our podcasts will be the bits that make it into the mashup.
You can either sort that out of the green room or alternatively not.
Yeah, it's tricky, right?
Because there's a part of me that's like, we should send an email and hash this out, and then there's a part of me that says, absolutely don't do that.
Have show notes.
Everyone can have their own show note format and you can discover if any of these podcasts don't have show notes at all.
Yes, yes, we could do that.
That one yeah, that one sounds mad.
I think Kevin's gonna keep you organized.
Is Kevin actually is Kevin actually you're gonna hear Kevin's voice?
You will Kevin is sometimes on Hugo Girl.
But not very often, yeah.
He made the boys one.
Yes.
And his cocktail sounded very lovely.
I was very jealous, Kevin.
Christopher J.
Garcia is running woof.
For those who don't know.
Woof is the World Order of Fan Editors.
Worldcon Order of Fan Editors.
Chris Garcia said it's the faux fishal
Which is it's a terrible pun.
Amateur Press Association of the WorldCom.
And basically, if you want to put something in Woof, you send an email to woofappa at gmail.
com before
7.
45 a.
m.
on the 30th of August.
I'm assuming that's Pacific Daylight Time.
Then it will be a online document which you will receive
from Chris on the thirtieth of August.
Hispania uh and I, Hispanian Sheriff and I have both had instalments in WOOF in the past.
And me.
So yeah, might might submit something.
And Alison.
I did the cover as well for
Duh what for a woof in the past?
Yeah no I'm hoping to get something in there.
Um yes I think I I like they're going all electronic
And so it will entirely be a all the contributions are submitted in in a single easily portable document format.
I thought that was quite funny.
It's a shame in a way
'Cause one of the great things about Woof is when you get the large stack of stapled paper and roughly half of them are US letter and the other half are A4 and it is a mishmash and that is fun.
But it will have that joy in PDF format
So so all you need to do to get that, John, is to print the US contributions out on letter format paper and print the UK contributions out on A4.
And as we all know, it's very easy to get letter format paper in Britain or in America.
Indeed,
Shall we do picks?
Yeah, so can I go first?
Is it because your pick is not an actual pick, it's like being in Spain?
Uh so so I have been to Spain before, but I haven't ever been on a Spanish beach holiday.
And it turns out the Spanish beach holidays are quite good fun.
And I can't I it amazes me that nobody told me this and I never knew it
And we were at this amazing beach yesterday and which is one of the just one of the local beaches and
I was like, this beach is amazing, this beach is much better.
It's not very full and it's absolutely gorgeous.
And and everyone was like, Yes, it turns out that Galicia would be the
Beach capital of Spain, were it not for the fact that everyone agrees that the water is really quite cold.
So I got in and compared with swimming with Meg in Whitley Bay in November that year
it was lovely and warm.
But compared to most other sea standards, it was fairly cold.
It was kind of as cold as you'd expect the sea to be off the coast of the UK.
So that's why, apparently, which means no jellyfish
'Cause they can't survive in this.
So it's lovely, absolutely lovely, it's amazing.
Oh my god, I'm just having so much fun.
Well I'm glad you're having fun.
Um I and and you know how all fun has to have a tiny little little bit of grit in the oyster
I could probably can't talk about the gritty of the oyster on the pod, but we're all having a good time at the moment.
Galicia's lovely, all the people are lovely, it is very cheap, it is very delicious.
Um
We w we had a day in Santiago.
Santiago's amazing.
We flew into the place in the world that is most famous for people getting there by foot.
And and so we did feel a
bit kind of square was thronged with happy pilgrims kind of arriving there tired and falling down and
kissing the stones and and waving their walking poles in the air and um and everything.
And then it's because it's everyone who goes there, apart from a few people who are eclipse chasing, is
at the end of their walking holiday, the atmosphere is very party.
I think even for Spain it's quite a party atmosphere 'cause they get to Santiago and then they just drink
And have fun.
Yeah.
So it's quite nice place.
I'm glad you're having fun.
My my so my pick is um Spain and then also Eclipse.
But I haven't seen an eclipse yet, so you know, I we'll keep you posted
Oh I see we're picking things from the future now.
I I I am very confident there's going to be a I um don't don't ask me how I know, but I'm in fact a priest, and I am very confident that something is going to eat the sun on
Wednesday?
I think it's Wednesday.
So uh before you get this podcast but after we record it.
How did I not know that Spanish holidays were fun?
I yeah, that is a bit baffling.
I mean I've been to Barcelona.
My only previous trip to Spain.
Right, shall I do my shall I do my pick next?
You can indeed do your pick next, Liz.
My pick is a book.
Uh my pick is a book called Notes from a Regicide by Isaac Fellman
It is essentially a sort of biography of a trans family of the two parents and their adoptive trans son.
And then in the background, basically
We are thousands of years in the future in a sort of post-industrial world in which their parents were revolutionaries who caused the downfall of a city-state monarchy and have fled to future New York.
But
That's basically all in the background.
It's really kind of a portrait of three very different people who all happen to be trans and how they found their way through life to the place they are in now.
And then sometimes events happen in the backdrop.
I think it's a very interesting book.
I think it is a very character driven portrait.
It's got some really lovely moments.
It is three people who are all frowned different ways.
They all come to their transition in different ways
They all have, you know, they're two revolutionaries but they kind of come to revolution in very different ways.
There's a lot about art and the power of art and
The power of art as uh propaganda and or tool of the revolution.
Yeah, it's just a it's a really nicely written book.
I think I would
have liked a little tiny bit more of the background to be in the foreground, but that's really not the point of the book.
And I enjoyed it.
Does it have a magician in it?
I mean it's got like a tarot deck.
Alright.
Is a magician a card in the tarot deck?
Yes, there is.
Yeah, excellent
Why is this relevant?
Well, it's genre in it.
Gotta ask incisive questions about genre.
It's definitely genre.
I mean really the fact that it is set kind of in the future is a bit wobbly because
There's obviously a thing about how we no longer have certain technology that we had in the past and there is some advanced technology, but it really doesn't kind of engage with that in a in a deep way.
It's just uh
This happens to be the situation and it enables one bit of the novel, which is that you can keep people in suspended animation for long periods of time.
That makes sense
That sounds good.
It's very good.
I am going to pick a book.
I am gonna pick A Thousand Blues by Chion Xion Ran, translated by Qi Yun King.
Which is a Korean book about a robot jockey who really likes horses.
It's
Interesting because it's covering very similar themes to Luminous
but it would be difficult to imagine a more different way of approaching them.
It's about a jockey and a young girl who finds the jockey and rescues him from the strap heap, uh basically.
And it's about sort of family and your obligations to each other, um, and also about what it being someone is and what it means to have agency as a someone.
And I really enjoyed it.
It's very contemplative.
It's um a translation from Korean.
The author is a um lives in South Korea.
Yeah, I really enjoyed it.
Um, so I would recommend that.
Was this another of your Clark books?
It was.
Because I also realised that by next episode we will know if you were a wronghead or not.
Um Yeah.
I f I feel we've done a lot of episodes of the podcast and we know he's a wronghead.
Alright, a very specific wronghead.
Yeah.
Uh uh well I mean, but it the judges collectively, so
For all you know, John might have died in a ditch for something.
Yeah, it was it was me, I was the only one supporting the good book, Liz.
Everyone else was the wrong head.
Mmm.
Honest.
Unless I agree with you, in which case obviously it's unanimous.
I mean I assume that the fact you're still here means the judges the judges' meeting went well or is it
Does this happen does this happen right before the award, I realise?
No, you've already done it, right?
It used to be that it was on the day of the award, but I believe that had changed that I
think that has not been true for some years.
Yeah, no, I think it used to be, and I think I always thought it was a bit kind of wild and mad because, you know Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, what if it's ten minutes the award and they're still having a big argument?
That was the Octothorpe podcast.
And it's goodbye for me.
It's goodbye from me.
This will be Octocon members.
This is gonna get quite complicated, isn't it?
Because I say Octo and I finish it Octothorpe every time.
I say Octo, you say Thorpe!
Yep that.
Yes, I imagine if you want to come you're going to have to join Octhor Octo Oh yeah no it is hard, isn't it?
The theme music for this episode was Surf Shimmy by Kevin McLeod and Combotech.
com used under a Creative Commons Attribution 4.
0 license.
This podcast will end at the beep.
Beep.